do you remember the feeling of like you
know just waking up every day was hard
was that are you that kind of guy who
gets depressed like I deal with
depression I deal with anxiety where you
sort of like can't get out of bed I'm a
failure is that where your mind goes I
had a series of a few things bomb and I
definitely I remember I was having
parties at my house a lot it was me and
my buddy stu okay yeah so Stu would come
over and he would bring people and we
would hang out I remember drinking like
wine I remember just not giving a
so I was self-destructive yeah I wasn't
like I was like let's get back on the
horse but I was like this is I needed to
vegetate so I was just yeah I was doing
whatever I wanted to do people don't
realize how depressed you can get like
I'm always about going to the next thing
but people don't realize that you give
your soul to something
yeah when it is stopped it is like
you're getting cut off